late lies the wintry sun a bed a frosty
fiery sleepy head blinks but an hour or
two and then
a blood red orange sets again
sunlight is powerful stuff perhaps more
powerful than most people realize every
aspect of how we function is controlled
by light in winter we're seeing a lot
less sunlight the petals of living
without sunlight are really quite real
in some ways modern life
has driven us back to the stone age okay
well we lived in caves in the 60s there
were several experiments by french
people who went into caves and stayed
there they all began to sleep either for
extraordinarily long periods of time or
extraordinarily short periods of time
and they couldn't tell the difference
they all said they had severe mood
disturbances and depression so much so
that some of them had to leave long
before they'd really had planned to
in winter
we often feel somewhat out of sorts at
this time of year a lack of sunlight
means that your immune system doesn't
work as well your defense mechanisms
don't work as well
an effect on mood increased depression
more metabolic disorders and all of
these things are offshoots of a
disrupted circadian clock
[Music]
at times all of our physiology and all
of our behavior
all of the active sorts of processes are
compartmentalized to the day and all of
the restorative processes are kept to
the night
the wavelengths that have the most
powerful impact are the
bluish colored ones within our eyes
there are these cells
that have a pigment that's sensitive to
this blue light that then signals to the
body clock to tell it what time of day
it is
[Music]
before the stars have left the skies at
morning
in the dark eyed eyes and shivering in
my nakedness
by the cold candle bathe and dress many
people don't realize what an artificial
life we live and that's because
artificial life depends on artificial
light so by seeking out artificial light
what that is doing is giving your body a
time cue that is incorrect then you
might end up feeling far more alert at
night
or a lot more depressed during the day
your systems within your body tend to
desynchronize and so you tend to have
higher incidence of diabetes obesity
cardiovascular disease
the world health organization sees shift
work as a threat to health and it is
many british people spend less than half
an hour a day in the open air
so it's no good staying inside and
looking at the sun and saying this is
doing me good because it isn't
so it's probably on a day like today
about four or five times less light
simply being on this side of the glass
a good dose of bright sunshine at any
time during the day
has a huge impact on elevating mood and
general feelings of well-being there was
a study at the broadmoor institute where
they looked at the effects of the
equivalent of 20 minutes of bright
sunshine in the morning on mood what
they found was the bright light had a
much greater effect on elevating mood
than even some antidepressants
when to go out my nurse stopped wrapped
me my comforter and cap the cold wind
burns my face and blows its frosty
pepper
so our skin's not just a barrier it's a
living organ when our skin sees sunlight
that is when it starts making vitamin d
which is an essential component of many
different signaling pathways in our body
you can get vitamin d in several ways
you can do what i do and take a vitamin
d pill a diet of wild salmon and
mushrooms and you won't get rickets but
overwhelmingly the best way is through
the sun
[Music]
it's coming back for generally
depressing reasons the amount of
sunlight we're getting gone down
dramatically in the last 20 years it's
gone down particularly fast in the last
two or three years we're not getting
outside and this is going to have an
impact on how well the body clock is
aligned it makes us even more like
hermits in a cave relying on artificial
light have meals at the right time go to
bed at the right time and get out even
if it's freezing for that daily
20-minute walk and some light exposure
simply being outside and exposing
yourself to light so that you strengthen
your circadian clock is
going to have a hugely beneficial impact
on health and well-being don't retreat
into your cave
in other words when the sun comes out
i'll go out and have a good time that's
the medical advice
black are my steps on silver sod
thick blows my frosty breath abroad
and tree
and house
and hill
and lake
are frosted
like a wedding cake
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video